we'll do a little debate club next get
back to where we know that's worst
vehicle we've ever had on here that is
quite a vehicle man first this is Alex
from st. Louis Alex looks like gills old
worker that used to work at fighter in
the kid what was that girl's name I
don't know but you and her have the same
nose that's my sister you're coming to
see you in Memphis we are so excited
we're driving all the way from st. Louis
to come see you
so I guarantee it's gonna be hilarious
yeah we love you guys related somehow
and thank you young lady uh Brennan
would somebody look into your tent even
hear your question can't we play it
between her nose and the tips have no
idea Alex some about ribs I have a
question for you I am a gamer all day
every day but I am a PlayStation girl so
what do you think it's better Xbox or
Playstation vo my sister and I are
coming to see you in Memphis we are so
excited we're driving all the way from
st. Louis to come see you so I guarantee
it's gonna be hilarious we love you guys
can't gang buzz buzz girl Congrats on
the nose oh yeah why are you making fun
of her no she's I'm married I think you
guys both have nice nose it you call me
potato nose all the time you text me
sometimes to say hey man heard you're
breathing really well feelings and
you'll often you'll text also this is a
something I've noticed and you'll say
instead of no K you know wo write in OSE
and then you'll [ __ ] say it was a
typo in my phone bro I'm thinking both
have nice noses okay well say that and
your cousin's come to see and you guys
should split some nice Memphis ribs well
look you had tits in your ears the first
time you can't even hear the woman and
she seemed like a lovely lady and I look
I love all these chick gamers man I like
seeing this Playstation or Xbox for me
it's PlayStation Xbox looks like you're
working for pharmaceutical sales or
something that thing's too [ __ ] big
you know it's white you can't hide it
that easily Xbox is
Xbox Xbox is black controller white
right they come in both colors they're
not when I was a kid is the Xbox the
Xbox started off as black you're the
first one was black PlayStation was it
like grey here's the thing Xbox all day
cuz the Xbox controllers big so she can
deal with that Xbox controllers can deal
with its dick we keep that touch me the
PlayStation small go get back in your
[ __ ] boat van and [ __ ] do a crime
you could someone yeah you're the one
who's flying a [ __ ] little of brown
guys around the country go [ __ ] no talk
about you Derek I'm actually just
talking about the other guy the [ __ ]
killer just don't how dangerous Brown
yeah dangerous brown out your [ __ ]
buddy man I'm joking I like you Sony's a
sweet guy yeah but we don't trust him
pain you play video games though right I
play Call of Duty right now and I play
by myself people keep asking me to get
on their team and [ __ ] dude I gotta
[ __ ] sleep I ain't tryin to [ __ ] be
talking to some men in different
countries [ __ ] at night yeah I probably
could I thought I had one in here until
you [ __ ] made fun of me am I sit both
of my sisters from Memphis okay
feel like you and your sisters and get
some trouble Memphis really walking in
Memphis where that Jam do won't you
reload your marks a lot and finish
putting your face on brother okay it's
something saying with that scattered
hair dude looks like a full grow a
complete beard what was she asking okay
what's this buckle bunny talking dude
buckle bunnies a fun term for people
that go to road sorry buckle buddy
yeah I'm gonna go to the radio soon as
I'm done pressure was [ __ ] I don't
play video games so but I grew up with
Xbox I was like the main business you
could start bruh
if you fight you up in a poor
environment practice your washing that
was the
dude that was like Ukraine an app at
Harvard change is like he's got his own
press room also makes you tell man Bank
Leonard's got his own pressure washing
company in he's [ __ ] bro to shout out
to anybody gets out there P dubbing dude
[ __ ] yeah and look both of my niece's
can come to the show and I'll say this
PlayStation it just looks swagger
I'm not turning on a [ __ ] Xbox plus
I'm a pedophile bro pedal Xbox is for me
seem like they're more in that pedophile
culture PlayStation to me seems a little
bit more fine dining if you will it's
for people with small hands okay
I'll take that 55% went with PlayStation
on the gang bro
you're an idiot I win this one dish that
out to the [ __ ]
Wow you're the kind of guy that hits all
the buttons that are on the table don't
even what they're doing it's called
button mashing
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]